girl answers now I'm gonna do all my
wires okay so I do my first integration
and what do you get
this is got a on this is a consonant
here right so it's going to grab a team
onto it letters G team but of course
it's still indefinite so I get another
Watson yeah they're constant right now
just like I did before me to use my
initial conditions which handily I have
written on the board already
when I say T equals zero why don't we V
sine alpha so on this constant a 0 here
and that's just your constant right
you'll end up with C 3 over here and B
sine alpha Q so that's what the constant
is so I've got Y dot equals minus GT
plus these are like so and then I
integrate a game to get to my
displacement right just like I did
before you can see a parallel right so
what happens to this guy minus GT will
become I think I'm just integrating with
the same time minus GT square on to and
you will frequently because we so often
get gravity given to us as tip you will
frequently get minus Phi T Square yeah
or you might get minus 4.9 T squared
since that comes you know with it this
attracts a teacher or to it and because
this is a fourth and final integration
what comes a local arrived final
constant varies yes okay yeah just like
before we had an initial condition
excuse me we're at the origin so when we
put in T equals 0 what happens to these
guys right why it was here because I'm
at the origin so what we'll see will be
0 that's nice ok great so lost
all six of our equations give yourself a
comeback now at this point you maybe you
want to put like another color around
the time what what are these things
these are our parametric equations for
displacement right are they right that
piece is a common trait and kind of be
closer than that so far but that's what
time is
it's a parametric sorry it's a primer so
these are the kind of equations right
two of them but I want you both together
into one now if I want you eliminate
excuse me time how my genius well if you
had simultaneously patience you don't
have to write this thing if you had some
same equations like this like now what
would you do this if you want to
eliminate a parameter value sorry a
variable at this right well you can take
this equation and see this one here what
is already the subject to you yeah so
you can substitute that directly into
here does that make sense
and once you do so this equation here
will no longer have Y's in it you've
eliminated a variable that's really good
that you want right the reason I can do
that is because in this case me why is
the subject so ideas public straining
yeah if Y is the subject I can
illuminate Y by putting it into a crazy
now what am I trying to eliminate
business I'm trying to run than 18 so
what should I change the subject of one
of these equations today
right now have a look at the left look
at the right which do you think might be
easier to make T is forbidden make it
this one right that's why I said I was
really showing this before
so we're going to take this equation
rather than deal with the square of the
square root a lot as far as attendance
equation and I don't have to do very
much
to make the subject team would lend you
to both sides divide by he points out
certainly to do with this now what I'd
like you to do that doesn't take very
long
there's maybe two lines each of it if I
didn't take this object and like we will
do here go ahead and substitute into
your one equations and eliminate three
you get to Antigua bit of simplification
to it I would say you can do that and
once you get that you will have every
study creating a path while you do that
I'm just gonna Brown obviously spaces on
here okay so that would be this writing
time you can see this is what happens is
when you just do a straight substitution
in there all I've done is replace all my
T's we okay now I can do a teen you can
simplify you might just sit meeting
things up a little bit so over here on
the left turn I'm gonna do something
which may be able to but you'll see why
I'm sorry I imagine you two things just
to this step number one you can see I've
got the con square alpha on the bottom
right but I have a whole ratio that's
devoted to when I've got reciprocals
right what - my father was one close
that would be a sex with him okay so I'm
gonna right now at the same time you'll
see why in a second I'm actually gonna
pull this x squared I'm gonna pull that
out separately okay
so I'm gonna write all of them you know
other stuff G + 2 + VN plus alpha will
say just wait alpha
I'm gonna write that wall to one side so
I'm gonna go like is minus G sick swear
Papa on to this way that's my B
coefficient and pull that out and I'm
going to do even right I'm gonna come up
X sweat and then over here what what
what canceling and simplifying can you
do you tell me what I can do sign up
plus alpha and that's just so it looks
like all I get is plus 10 alpha again
even though slightly unconventional or
go right at first and then what's left
find is annex
tada hey presto this is the equation of
pop okay yeah do not attempt to memorize
this it's not worth it and it's also
just pensive brain and every time you
have to use this if you never have to
use it you have to prove it so don't
wanna be once again
hey I mean you can't buy them and put a
box around if you like but I just want
to point out a few things about this
okay and you can see I put these guys
here this is why I third president
rearrange its orbit way so these are
highlighted right so I want you to look
at this guy here right it's call these
coefficients on television it's got all
these protons in it right but Jake I
want you to notice it's a constant like
10 or 9 or whatever buddies closed it
with a task bar is couple what like
what's actually represent I brought all
the diagrams and special relation it's
your angle of projection right now could
say angle of inclination because it is
the angle a condition can change right
at certain points trees up with a new
equation might be 0 the angle of
inclination might be dropping down cuz
its name of depression okay but alpha
does not change his where is alpha it's
at the origin at time 0 when you first
launch this thing right in other words
outfit is a cluster
does that make sense so that means sex
wear a base without the ways that in
this context just to be careful because
in different question if they'll say P
is different based in this context what
do you say therefore gives your initial
losses writes your projection speed okay
in other words it's a cluster right so
all of this despite have discussed in
your books it's just a number right it
might be like that
three good or the 2.1 or whatever it's
all the constant this is where the
action is happening right so mean this
here is just a constant also negative
the negative constant here
and if your acquaintance has exquisite
X's in it what kind of a shape is it
going to give you it's a parabola
right because this is a quadratic in X
that shape should be drawing a strabo
all this time is actually a travel
you'll be careful normal things that
just look like they are but we have just
proved that the path that a projectile
takes is always is a parabola so that's
kind of really big takeaway from this
proof okay right now
why don't we care about this okay I gave
you a reason to care and do you know
what the reason was like why would we
bother eliminating T is that took a long
time what kinds of questions do you get
asked often projectile issue questions
what kind of the question is often where
right where is something happening often
we took care when it happens we just
care where players or where it rebounds
away or where it is at the highest point
okay so this equation here we'll give
that to you really creeps my okay